what's going on guys this is Rob and I
just got back from seeing Suicide Squad
first things first I'm actually testing
out a new camera and a new microphone so
let me know how you guys feel about this
and hopefully it's it's pretty good
quality I won't really know until until
I get into post but to the topic at hand
Suicide Squad so what did I think about
it well for me Suicide Squad was amazing
it was it was an amazing movie but
that's because I went into it knowing
what to expect and for those of you guys
who are going into the Suicide Squad
film expecting something tantamount to
Captain America's Civil War or the
Winter Soldier or the Avengers or
swimming along those lines you're gonna
find yourself disappointed the Suicide
Squad would never design for that
purpose the Suicide Squad largely
consisted of characters who were
considered to be unsellable with the
exception of Harley Quinn she's always
done well but that's because she was in
Batman the Animated Series through the
whole different story behind that but
the rest of the characters are really
just kind of an ongoing location but the
Suicide Squad was really popular because
of the fact and that anybody could die
at any one particular moment now having
said that when it came to the movie were
there elements of it that I didn't
really care for yes but the only one
element that I didn't like was the plot
and that's only because the plot was
spinned
even for coming book film there's really
good of del to deal with a little more
meat and potatoes in order to deep it up
a bit but it's not the man I thought
everything else was on point the
characters were very well designed for
what they needed to be the characters of
Harley Quinn and Deadshot were clearly
the front-runner it's just because Will
Smith is such a big name actor and
margot robbie is a beautiful woman and
Harley Quinn's a very anticipated
character since this is the first time
that were actually seeing her in coming
before I'm sorry in in film form in any
kind of Chromebook movie but it's not
from that the movie was was stellar
you know this movie felt like if the
Punisher and Deadpool had a love child
and that child was a team that had
Harlequin and that being said you know
this this movie right now is ranked
number 2 in terms of
my favorite movies of this year first
Captain America's Civil War being number
one but this movie is right behind it
this was really just high-octane fast
paced movie cliches you know it was it
wasn't trying to be anything special it
was trying to be what the comics were
but what was even better about this
movie was the fact that it had so much
tie in this movie really is is one of
those films that solidified the fact
that there is a big cohesive DC Universe
out there that Batman vs Superman that
the Man of Steel the upcoming Batman
movie the Justice League whatever movies
are going out Wonder Woman that these
films are all going to be part of a
larger DC Universe this would be tied
into that extremely well especially the
the post-credits scene which you guys
need to check out it really stood to me
as something just fun and entertaining
and no frills and there wasn't some deep
understanding of the characters you know
in terms of why they were doing what
they did it was pretty straightforward
now in terms of the characters
themselves of course we talked about
Holland when we talked about Will Smith
Amanda Waller that character was amazing
um I absolutely loved Amanda Waller in
this she was Amanda Waller she was the
Amanda Waller that I remember from
before the new 52 for those of you guys
who loved the pre new 52 Amanda Waller
this is the one for you for those of you
guys who like the new 52 Amanda Waller
not really sure you're gonna find what
you're looking for here but that doesn't
mean this Amanda Waller is not great
it's it's she's she's she's hardcore
she's cutthroat she is ruthless I mean
she is exactly what you'd expect for a
woman in her position she is you know
she's the person you don't want to cross
it's how she come to cost you know again
the character of Deadshot of Will Smith
was was pretty stellar the character of
Harley Quinn was and it was sexy I'll be
quite honest who was that that crazy
sexy appeal but they were that that
Warner Brothers was going for and they
did a great job doing that of course
there were a lot of scenes where Margot
Robbie
/ and you know we were kind of allowing
her to show off what she was working
with which I didn't mind but in terms of
the other characters Captain Boomerang
was a small-time villain in DC Comics
he's a small-time flash villain and he
always will be he'll never be a major
character in DC Comics and in this movie
who is not a major character but he did
have some great moments again without
spoiling anything there's a really great
segment of him where he basically just
bails out and it's really funny it's
really cool to see it happen you know
the character of Rick Flagg is a great
character they do a little bit of
explanation in-depth understanding about
him but I didn't really want to know too
much about his past as far as I needed
to know he was the leader of the Suicide
Squad the field commander directly under
Amanda Waller and that's what one of
others gave us that's what they provided
to us the character of of Jared Leto's
Joker I think this is really gonna be a
big talking point here the first
question we have to ask is can anybody
follow up to beef Ledger's Joker from
The Dark Knight the answer to that
question is no no one's gonna be able to
compete with Keith ledger but it was
still a great performance this Joker
felt something I can to the 1950s goofy
you know Meets The Killing Joke meets
the classic 1940s Joker all sort of
world into one is it Etha Ledger's Joker
no and Jared Leto I don't think was
going for that instead he gave us
something all his own something you meet
the Joker was sane but insane at the
same time and it was a great blend of
these two concepts it was you know Joker
being a mastermind organising things but
he was always a background character did
I feel like the movie needed him no the
movie did not need the Joker to the in
it it was good to see him it was nice to
see him but it wasn't a requirement it
really could have been fine without him
there and maybe it would have made a
little more sense a few times if he
wasn't part of the story but he was and
you know for the way that he was written
he didn't perfectly fine for the most
part you know if I'm gonna give this
movie a rating I'd stay in terms of you
know in relation to counter book films
again I put it as my second favorite
film of the year but again we still have
Doctor Strange to look forward to and
that may very well take the number two
spot and Suicide Squad gets bumped down
the number
in terms of my overall view of every
time book movie that's been made up to
this point yeah the Suicide Squad
counter rates around the bottom of the
top 10s lis pendens going against movies
like captain america civil war Captain
America the Winter Soldier
Iron Man 1 you know x-men Days of Future
past it's going against some strong
competition you know the Man of Steel
you know when it comes to become a book
film so I wouldn't say this is one of
the greatest movies ever made in the
realm of comics for what I will say is
that it's unique they'd give us villains
who were acting as superheroes whether
it's because they were conscripted or
because they chose to you know it is the
quintessential example of the Suicide
Squad and comics translated into film
but having said you guys are gonna go
ahead and wrap this up post comments
below let me know what you guys think
about the Suicide Squad movie I'm really
curious to see your all's opinions you
know catch you all later please